um for you though
like have you gotten the itch to like
kind of you know maybe pop in on a video
here and there you know like yeah the so
Kyle hit me up and was like after we
shot that obviously like the fans were
cool with it like everyone everyone
liked it yeah and he was just like dude
I'm just going to let you know every
time we're shooting a video what we're
doing like and if you want to get down
yeah pop into whatever you want so um
yeah that's I haven't shot anything else
since that but cuz obviously I'm I'm
like pretty locked into a [__]
schedule of what I'm building the new
clothes the new clothes the new brand
mhm mhm so many I would't even call it a
clothing brand it's just a brand yeah a
lot of things I saw on Xbox yeah that
[__] was sexy super crazy yeah yeah the
craziest Xbox I've ever seen this [__]
would you guys have to take it apart
paint it or did somebody do it for yeah
I had to go through like a middleman
company to buy the Xboxes and then and
they did designed them oursel and then
we got them to like like do it to them
but we're doing the same thing with uh
cuz we have a '90s drop coming out and
uh we're doing uh 10 Game Boy Colors oh
so it's kind of sick it's like Game Boy
Color but in our color it's going be
sick that's great um yeah so for you now
you just kind of have the option
whenever you want to film hey yeah I
want to do the Bigfoot thing or yeah
yeah which is like I never didn't want
to do pranks that's why I did [__] hole
why about to say when you were doing
[__] hole you did some great [__] like
um you had the old man that I just saw
at a random restaurant in the valley oh
eaten Park in Burbank I was there with
my parents and I saw that old dude who
was like oh Gramps yeah yeah yeah yeah
Gramps and I was just
like that's the dude well he's like a
straight up actor tons of [__] he's a
great [__] actor but yeah no I saw
him I was like that's the [__] old
man from the [__] uh the the the
Jesse videos yeah yeah I mean [__] hole
was dope I mean for you at the
moment documenting kind of the new what
Sunday is right the brand you've been
putting so much into so much work into I
told you off camera I was like it's
crazy cuz I kind of feel like I've just
been
watching this thing since like
incubation just come alive on YouTube
and now you're obviously having success
you had the pop-up shop yeah um Rose it
feels like everything's just flying I
mean you know you're dropping it out
yeah
and uh for you like I guess what is
your you have so much going on you train
you're working out you got the brand
you're shooting Vlogs content all of
that what is kind of like your like most
of your energy going into because you
also eventually want to kind of help do
stuff for other brands right yeah we're
currently already doing that right now
oh dope just we uh we slowed down at the
start like the like you were saying
you've seen like like you it feels like
you like know Sunday from the start you
can like feel how the whole operation
works we got like I've said this before
but like that's why we got so much hate
on it cuz it was like we were so
transparent that we like didn't even
know what the [__] company was like
we were figuring it out and people were
seeing us figure it out which again I
think long term is paying off cuz now
people are like whoo now I now I
understand all the moving Parts but um
yeah the the only thing with the working
for other people and designing their
[__] is it is super complicated unless
if you do if you do six out of 10 things
for that company and they commission you
to do that but then they [__] up the
other four and it doesn't sell or it
doesn't work and they want yeah and they
want to blame you for not working and
you're like well you didn't know how to
Market or you didn't know how to you
know whatever it was whatever it is so I
think the key is coming in and in the
future it'll be like Venture Studio
absorbing companies like taking half
their company small that we believe in
and so that we care help build them up
yeah and we can do everything for them
but like if you kind of become a partner
and you make it vertical like fully
vertical and don't do too many of them
just like true yeah don't take on too
much cuz then you're going to I mean
everything gets watered down if you're
going to do that you know what I'm
saying yo it's crazy because I remember
the way you were talking about like the
blank and how important it was to find
the right blank yeah and like what like
did you guys have to cuz there's so many
blanks out there there's like Los
Angeles apparel and uh uh is La apparel
the big thick one that I like pause
super pause yeah
um but like for you guys yeah all that
right so like how did you find the blank
or did you create the blank create
everything's created so everything we
sell is completely custom but it's uh I
would say it it's a Frankenstein of a
bunch of different shirts so like For
That t-shirt it was like it has a little
bit of an acne studi blank it like
that's where the boxy fit came the the
fabric was like some shirts that we
liked but it was also came down to just
Tyler who's part of our sourcing team
who just he knows every single fabric we
go field Fabrics like we sampled that
shirt like 12 times so it just kept
frankensteining until we were like this
is the perfect shirt at a perfect price
point and do you go to China to feel
Fabrics just curious I haven't yet no
feels he he is our like connection to
that he's he's the guy who's got the
Chinese plugs yeah but we're also doing
a lot of [__] domestically too we're
trying to as much as we can I mean
that's dope yeah if you don't have to
Outsource could support some American
companies why wouldn't you no 100% And
you or North American companies cuz
shout out to Canada yeah we're all in
this together you know and
Mexico